οποιος δήποτε τι είναι η πρωτεραότητα σου αυτή τη στιγμή είναι η δημιουργεία κουλτούρας επιτυχίας
στων οργανισμοκουρτούρ επιτυχία στην οποία θεωρείται ότι έχουν και η παλίλη του οργανισμού εμα είναι
το βασικό στιχίων του να δημιουργήσεις κουρτούρα είναι να πάει σε όλον των κόσμοδηλαδή χωρίς
να πρέπει να πεις κάτι να γίνεται όταν δεν είσαι εκεί αυτό που λέει ο
κόσμος δεν είναι αυτό που θα άλεγες ανίσουν εκεί αυτόν είναι δύσκολο εξαιρετικά δύσκολο διότι
η μιλάς για έναν οργανισμό δύοχιλιάδων ατόμον ι οποί έχουν μεγαλώσει στη σίτα ικαριέρα σχεδό
της πολύ μεγαλη πλιοψυφίας τούς είναι μόνο ησδα έχουν μάθει από κουλρτούρες προηγούμενον χρόνον που
είναι πολύ διαφορετικές κουρτούρες δημοσίου και πρέπει να αλλάξει ο τρόπος που σκέφτονται για να
πάν σε αυτό που λέμε κουρτούρα συνεχούς επιτυχίας νομίζω ότι επιδίκουρ τούραξεκινά από πάνω σε
πολύ μεγαλο βαθμόν τα πιο πανοστρόματα έχουν καταφέρει να πειτύχουν αυτή την αλλαγή και υ
πρόκληση μας τώρα είναι να πάμε και στον κόσμο πιο κατό ακόμα και στον κόσμον
οποίος είναι στα καταστήματα είναι στο κόςε στα συνεργεία μας και βλέπει τους πελάτες καθημερινά
αυτός ο κόσμος την ώρα με ό πιο δήποτε τρόπον μιλά με τους πελάτες έχει
οποια δήποτε επαφή με τους πελάτες να βγαίνει αυτή η κουρτούρα και πια εντουτικούς τούρα
η υρτούραενός οργανισμού οποίος είναι πελάτεο ο γεντρικώς ο οποίος βάζιζη πάντα σε πρό την
πρωτεραιότητα των πελάτη δηλαδή δε σκέφτεισε ότι η οπελάτης είναι εδώ για α ζητήσει κάτι
από μένα